ce serait un message pour un autre
témoin que vous connaissez pas que vous
avez découvert là comme ça charbonneau
pensé pour être adressé ou passéiste
sérieusement ça va changer votre vie au
maximum - d'une certaine forme stijn
meuris cd j'étais vraiment exposés mais
quelqu'un qui qui qui qui est un oiseau
bauer un sauna ryanair mais qui est peu
commun mais com - c'est d'un capot cet
avis il va pas une chance qui va ruiner
sa vie c'est plate à dire mais je ne
crois pas que le système est fait à ce
moment pour défendre ce qu'ils dénoncent
et plein d'autres personnes qui ont
dénoncé le système syndical
mais comme c'était pas mélanger ce
n'était pas le meilleur temps ce n'est
pas exactement son parti dans
l'oubliette en burnout ou en retraite
ouais pour x raisons gelé les étoiles
sont alignées médias et elle est où la
police était d'un bon ben je vais tout
était aligné bien pour qu'il fasse en
sorte qu' on est exposé sur la
commission été développé c'est quelque
chose que peu de personne puis le belge
exposé quelque chose puis en même temps
une commission si ça arrive ce des loges
j'ai eu à n'importe qui qui veut
dénoncer la bonne affaire c'est dénoncer
mais il ya des conséquences énormes